So the directory is a distributed
structure across the cores.
It's not centralized in one place,
like the bus.
So not all requests have to go to
the same part of the directory.
Each slice of the directory
will serve a set of blocks,
where a slice of the directory is the
part of the directory that is next to
a particular core.
And that means that different blocks
will be served by slices that
are in different places.
And that's how we achieve a higher
bandwidth because really each slice
could operate independently because
it serves a disjoint set of blocks.
What does a slice do?
It has one entry for
each block served by that slice.
And the entry for a block tracks
which caches in the system
have this block in an non-invalid state,
of course,
because the block in an invalid state
is like it's not in that cache at all.
And the order of accesses for
a particular block is determined
by the home slice for that block.
That's the slice of the directory
that has the entry for this block.
We call that the home
slice of the directory.
So pretty much,
accesses that go to the same block
are almost serialized in how
they can access their entry.
And the order in which that happens
is the order in which the accesses
are officially said to happen.
Note that with a directory protocol,
the caches still have the same
states they did with snooping.
It's just now when we
send a request to read or
write, that request no
longer goes on a bus.
It gets sent via our
network to the directory.
So we can have many requests
traveling to their individual slices.
And then the directory
figures out what to do.